well in shohei ohtani as we all know is
the man they're going to be squaring off
making his
major league baseball career high
22nd start of the season kaipe
and for this guy
right now finishing on a high note
whether or not this might be his last
start i think is important for him
moving into the offseason but really
i think it's just an honor and a
pleasure to be able to watch this man
take them out and do what he's done on
the mound as well as offensively
first pitch swinging in the air and
there's your quick out gooby oh that is
impressive i thought bob melvin did a
great job as far as putting tony kemp at
the top of the order work counts he's up
there hacking first pitch you love it
and he got him ohtani
next pitch and there's one there chased
and missed took a little something off
that splitter at 87.
we're taking on the strong right-hander
frankie montos making his 30th start of
the season against the angels
organization he's pitched very well
against really over his
career four and one two five nine era
and that's over the course of 12
appearances nine of those being starts
it's that one hard but right at kemp
shohei ohtani will be in the batter
3-2 delivery shohei takes and that
misses low
and he is on with a one-hour walk no
balls in two strikes here's the pitch
swung out of missed a good split down
and in great pitching
pitch jam shot
and chapman with the shift on is going
to pick it up he'll hustle over to the
bag
might be playable walsh
to the rail and he's there and makes the
catch another out on a splitter so far
of the season shelly o'tanio on o2
counts hitters one for now 47.
and he grounds this one right to
randhifo the shift on the right side the
shortstop will field and throw him out
and so that will be out number two
chapman lightens one headed for the left
field corner
over there is gosselin to pick it up and
matt chapman with a loud double his
third hit in the series his second
double
got him
brown goes down
scoreless ball game randhifa with 200
a lot of time in triple a this year
frankie's pitches bounced to the right
side right to second account and tony
throws to first and one out that'll
bring up jose rojas
that one is ripped toward right field
but brown is there he's got it
frankie ball on the outside corner ring
him up strike three called and stassi
can't believe that eight nine and one
golems elvis andrews and then back to
the top of the order one two breaking
ball that's it high in the outer left
center field on the run is marsh to the
track at the wall and on to the rock
garden for yon gomez a hanging slider
from shohei ohtani and gomes sends it on
a long ride over the wall and left
center and it's one nothing oakland man
as soon as ohtani let go but and saw the
contact from gomes he knew what the
result was going to be
one nothing oakland runner at second
base one out for marte who swung through
a slider his first time up
got him there
and so here's marketa so canada with two
on and two out here's the o2
this one's hit right in front of home
plate right where max dassey comes out
fires to first and matt will end the
inning good split by shohei good job to
get out of that jam right there
ball's hit to left and hit pretty well
going back looking up
and it is off the road
marsh to second while otani as a pitcher
has just
for the first time
in his career
issued an intentional walk he's seen
this a lot as a hitter already
[Music]
and he got him because the batter will
be matt chapman
that one is hit deep center field and
that baby is gone chapman with a home
run is 26th of the year and the a's lead
to nothing another blast off the rocks
in the outfield pack your bags chappie
all aboard next stop pound town
up the middle past montos andrews the
throw to first got him
[Applause]
you
shot montas bare hand flips to first
fletcher's out
two out nobody on and here's the pitch
frankie throws and that swung out of
miss a split in the dirt marsh k is a
one two three frame for montas and after
five the athletics lead the angels to
nothing
here's the next delivery this is chopped
a short could be two flipped to second
relay on the first that's a double play
chapman is retired
joe hey otani will be the first batter
for the angels ohtani against frankie
this leads to nothing around the front
and drops it but too close to the
mountain and montas throws to first just
in time
frankie throws in it's swung on in a
shot
speared at second by kemp throws the
first for the out here's the fish to
walsh now and that swung on and popped
up and that's playable short right kept
drifting out he's right there to make
the catch and what a job frankie montas
has one hit the angels through six
innings
make it seven
i guess he didn't have a great feel for
a slider if he's going to a splitter and
there it is again boy again
oh magnificent
[Applause]
the other two fellas not afraid to dial
up a ground ball that's true
him
nasty
got him splitter struck him out seven
strikeouts for montas
it's a big day for chapman with the two
extra base hits they lead from first
second and third pleasant weather though
today here's the pitch and there's a
swing and a miss he struck him out on a
slider
picks up his tenth strikeout of the day
now these have a loaded and here's olson
quijada needs it out here
high pop-up
who wants it
mayfield and quijada it's mayfield
who makes the catch sliding
[Applause]
got that one though down the line and
fair
and into the corner
and gosling stayed on the breaking ball
and he's got a double
runners at second and third
one out here in the bottom of the ninth
jose rojas will be the next batter
line base hit
goslin scores
holding third is walsh high throw
two outs in the inning mayfield for
three
strike three call but a good job by
canna he advances the base runner still
nobody out runners on the corners here
against jed lowry
[Music]
and he hits one high in the air
should be deep enough gosling's there
he's got it lowery with a sac fly
to give the a's
a 3-2 lead so just like that quickly the
a's grab the lead back
fletcher taps it chapman's got it now
they're going to have the runner at
second mayfield in a rundown
harrison with the pump fake and they tag
him and going to second no staying at
first is
fletcher
[Applause]
throw to first and safe at first
trailing three to two here in the bottom
of the tenth and wong will be the pinch
hitter
that one is hit hard to right field
coming in as brown he's got it and
that's the ball game
[Applause]